madame la ministre mes chers collègues
madame la rapporteur nous poursuivons
cet après-midi les travaux de notre
commission d'enquête par l'audition de
Madame Agnès Buzin en sa qualité
d'ancienne ministre de la Santé je vous
remercie madame la ministre de vous êtes
mobilisés pour cette audition
hématologue de formation vous a été
nommé de formation et toujours
hématologue vous avez été nommé ministre
des Solidarités de la Santé dans le
gouvernement Édouard Philippe le 17 mai
2017 et avait conservé cette fonction
jusqu'au 16 février 2020 votre
expérience est à deux titres
principalement susceptibles d'éclairer
les travaux de la commission d'enquête
d'une part vous avez été ministre au
début de la crise sanitaire et notre
assemblée vous a d'ailleurs déjà
auditionnée dans le cadre de sa
commission d'enquête constituée sur les
leçons de l'épidémie de covid-19 à
propos de la gestion et de la façon dont
s'est déroulé l'accompagnement des
premiers signaux d'alerte et puis la
mise en oeuvre évidemment de
des procédés de prévention de gestion de
stock de masques notamment pendant la
crise au début d'une crise qui était
assez violente assez brutale et assez
massive vous nous indiquerez donc
quelles leçons vous tirez de cette
période puisque concernant la
constitution de stocks stratégique et
notamment nous en nous ce qui nous
concerne une question qui revient
régulièrement celle de la question des
médicaments puisque nous sommes en
situation de pénurie mais des Strokes
stratégiques de médicaments sont
évidemment peuvent évidemment nous
concerner dans d'autres situations
sanitaires et le rôle de l'État face à
une crise sanitaire donc de grands
ampleur en l'occurrence c'était une
pandémie d'autre part et surtout
indépendant de indépendamment de la
crise sanitaire la période durant
laquelle vous avez occupé vos fonctions
ministérielles a été marquée par
d'importantes difficultés en matière
d'approvisionnement en médicament c'est
le sillon d'ailleurs motivé
l'établissement en juillet 2019
d'une feuille de route
2019-2022 réunissant 28 mesures pour
lutter contre les pénuries et améliorer
la disponibilité des médicaments en
France celle-ci était structurée autour
de 4 axes le premier promouvoir la
transparence et la qualité de
l'information afin de rétablir la
confiance et la fluidité entre tous les
acteurs le second lutter contre les
pénuries de médicaments par des
nouvelles actions de prévention et de
gestion sur l'ensemble du circuit toute
la chaîne finalement de valeur du
médicament le troisième renforcer la
coordination nationale et la coopération
européenne pour mieux prévenir les
pénuries médicaments j'ajouterai que le
passage par l'épidémie covid-19 a donné
un tour particulièrement intéressant à
ce troisième axe et le quatrième mettre
en place une nouvelle gouvernance
nationale
et donc vous pourrez nous indiquer dans
quel contexte cette feuille de route a
été définie et nous décrire la manière
dont elle a été reçue et mise en œuvre
par les
des acteurs de la chaîne surtout et
alors que la feuille de route n'a
manifestement pas permis d'en Diguer
l'aggravation du phénomène des pénuries
vous nous indiquerez de quelle manière
il est possible selon vous d'aller plus
loin rappelons que à l'été 2018 une
mission avait été réalisée par le Sénat
à laquelle nous participions madame la
rapporteur et moi-même concernant la
pénurie de médicaments à l'époque il y
avait à peu près 700 médicaments pénurie
nous sommes suivant
les critères et suivant le moment entre
2500 et un peu plus de 3000 médicaments
en pénurie actuellement donc il y a eu
vraiment une massification de de cette
question des pénuries
et vous dire aussi que les quatre axes
finalement reprennent ce que nous avions
déjà aussi particulièrement
identifié au moment de la remise de
cette du rapport de cette mission
d'information sur l'ensemble de ces
sujets madame la ministre je vais vous
céder la parole
pour un bref propos introductif puis
madame Laurence Cohen rapporter heureux
de notre commission d'enquête vous
poserez une première série de questions
comme vous l'aurez compris notre
commission d'enquête entend obtenir des
réponses étayées à des questions
précises sur je le conseille une
question qui n'est pas simple qui est
multifactorielle mais qui mérite
néanmoins que on met un point d'honneur
à trouver des réponses les plus précises
possibles pour être le plus rapidement
efficace je précise que cette audition
est diffusée en direct sur le site
internet du Sénat et qu'elle fera
l'objet d'un compte-rendu publié avant
de vous donner la parole je vous
rappelle qu'un faux témoignage devant
notre commission d'enquête et passible
des peines prévues aux articles
434-13 434-14 et 434-15 du code pénal je
vous invite madame la ministre à activer
votre micro est prêté serment de dire
toute la vérité rien que la vérité en
levant la main droite et en disant je le
jure
je le jure je vous remercie et je vous
donne la parole
madame la présidente Madame la
rapporteur mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs
je suis en fait très intéressée de cette
conversation avec vous sur les pénuries
de médicaments parce que c'est un sujet
qui m'a beaucoup préoccupé avant même
d'être ministre lorsque j'étais
hématologue puisque j'avais déjà dans
mon exercice professionnel eu des
difficultés à traiter des malades avec
des médicaments anciens très peu cher
qui n'intéressait pas du tout
l'industrie et pour lequel j'avais
réussi à l'époque c'était près de 20 ans
à mobiliser je crois la Pharmacie
centrale des hôpitaux pour qui nous
fabriquent à façon un médicament qui
était utilisé peut-être sur une
cinquantaine de patients par an en
France et qui donc n'avait vraiment plus
de marché intéressant donc c'est quelque
chose que j'ai vu arriver dans les
années 2000 je l'ai senti également
lorsque je dirigeais l'Institut National
du Cancer puisque les médicaments
anti-cancéreux étaient parfois en
tension je me souvenir notamment de
arrête de production pour des raisons
que je n'avais pas bien comprises du
vaccin BCG par Sanofi qui était utilisée
dans les cancers des vessies et il n'y
avait pas de traitement de substitution
donc il avait fallu faire des
recommandations professionnelles pour
essayer de trouver des alternatives à un
traitement qui était indispensable
donc voilà c'est un sujet qui m'a
mobilisé en tant que professionnel et
qui évidemment lorsque je suis arrivée
ministre m'a mobilisé pour trouver des
solutions parce qu'une fois que vous
êtes aux manettes vous devez évidemment
trouver comment régler les problèmes
qu'affrontent les professionnels et
surtout les citoyens
quand je suis arrivé les pénuries de
médicaments avaient été multipliées par
20 en l'espace de 10 ans on était passé
de 44 pénuries en 2018 à 868 en deux en
2008 44 pénuries en 2008 contre 868 en
et donc j'ai je savais déjà à cette
époque là que les causes étaient
multifactériennes mais j'avais du mal à
avoir un état des lieux pour l'ensemble
des médicaments utilisés sur le
territoire et donc j'ai mandaté à
l'époque au fonctionnaire de défense et
de sécurité le général Arnaud Martin qui
était donc
aux frontières de défense et de sécurité
au sein du ministère de la Santé
dépendant du secrétariat général qui
donc en charge des questions de
souveraineté et notamment de
souveraineté économique
de me rendre un état des lieux pour
essayer de savoir quel était les risques
où se situaient les risques quel type de
médicaments étaient les plus à risque de
pénurie et d'évaluer en réalité notre
niveau de dépendance
au niveau français concernant les
médicaments indispensables alors il a
réduit son
son travail à la liste des médicaments
indispensables qui avaient été produite
par la NSM en 2008 donc il s'était
reposé là-dessus qui donnait déjà un bon
une bonne idée du paysage et son constat
était le suivant alors je l'ai repris
pour votre commission donc son constat
c'était que pour deux tiers des
médicaments
considérés comme indispensables en 2008
il y avait clairement une redondance des
sites de production et des détenteurs
d'AMM
157 médicaments n'étaient produits que
par un seul laboratoire mais avait mais
disposé d'au moins deux sites de
production et 98% de ces sites étaient
au sein d'Union Européenne donc 44% en
France
les médicaments
les plus pour lesquels nous avions une
plus grande dépendance semblait être les
médicaments d'infectiologie c'est-à-dire
antibiotiques antiviraux
22% d'entre eux étaient fabriqués sur un
site unique et 74% étaient situés hors
de France mais ce qui m'avait vraiment
alerté dans son rapport qui était une
note en fait c'était un deux pages qui
faisait vraiment un état des lieux c'est
que 80% des médicaments indispensables
en France avait recours à des API je
pense que c'est un terme que vous avez
dû utiliser maintenant une fois mais
donc à des principes actifs qui
n'étaient pas fabriqués au sein de
l'Union européenne
quand on regarde les stocks des
médicaments indispensables fait par les
industriels ils étaient extrêmement
variables de l'ordre de deux semaines
jusqu'à 6 mois selon les médicaments et
quand on les interroge sur
l'adaptabilité de leurs outils de
production des industriels répondaient
avec le ils avaient moyen d'adapter leur
ligne de production en cas de tension en
cas de pénurie mais que ça nécessitait
des délais de mise en forme de leur
ligne de production qui varier de 3 à 9
mois parce qu'ils sont quand même des
délais conséquents mais que surtout à
partir du moment où on utilisait une
chaîne de production pour fabriquer un
produit en pénurie il y avait évidemment
un retentissement sur d'autres produits
et donc on prenait un risque sur
d'autres produits qui étaient fabriqués
sur la chaîne et donc on risque d'avoir
des tensions ailleurs
donc c'était quand même un rapport
inquiétant 80% des médicaments
indispensables ont des principes actifs
fabriqués en dehors de l'Union
Européenne je pense que c'est vraiment
pour nous
l'alerte maximum et je reviendrai
peut-être
à la commentaire que vous avez fait sur
la crise covid puisque c'est exactement
ce que nous avons subi concernant les
masques alors les causes de rupture je
pense que vous les avez vu dans cette
commission elles sont extrêmement
variables d'un produit à l'autre parce
que les chaînes de production font
l'objet de très nombreux États souvent
les produits passent par différents pays
d'ailleurs à l'occasion du brexit
lorsque les contrôles douaniers allaient
être remis en place avec l'Angleterre on
avait identifié tout un tas de chaînes
de production qui allait être ralentie
par ces mesures douanières parce que les
boîtes étaient fabriquées aux États-Unis
ou la galénique en Angleterre ou la
galinique est donc on voit bien que
toutes ces étapes où le médicament
voyage en réalité entre son principe
actif initial et puis la boîte finale
qui est distribuée en France peuvent
être l'objet de rupture parce que une
usine a brûlée parce qu'il y a une
contamination bactérienne dans une dans
une production etc et ce qui m'avait le
plus marqué je crois c'est en 2019 on
nous avions subi une pénurie de
corticoïdes je crois qu'il y a pas de
médicaments plus indispensables
quasiment que les corticoïdes vraiment
ça sauve des vies tous les jours et en
fait personne n'avait été vraiment
alerté par le risque de pénurie des
corticoïdes du fait de le nombre de
d'industriels qui produisent des
corticoïdes sous différents dosages sous
différentes formes galéniques et voilà
des sites de production sont extrêmement
nombreux donc il y avait pas
d'inquiétude et en réalité en tirant le
fil jusqu'au bout un des principes
actifs étaient fabriqués en Chine et les
Chinois pour une raison x ou y avait été
obligé d'arrêter leur chaîne de
production en Chine et de fait le
retentissement et la pénurie sur les
corticoïdes étaient mondiales et touché
évidemment tous les fabricants alors
il se trouve que j'ai beaucoup travaillé
sur les pénuries mais aussi non
seulement de médicaments mais aussi les
pénuries en ressources humaines dans le
monde de la santé et de mon passage à
l'Organisation mondiale de la santé
pendant deux ans entre 2021 et 2022
enfin 2021 de 21 22 j'ai beaucoup
regardé en fait ce qui se passait au
niveau mondial et j'ai un peu mieux
compris ce que nous subissions de plein
fouet en France sans en avoir vraiment
anticipé les effets
en réalité toutes les pénuries sont
mondiales que ce soit les pénuries de
médicaments comme les pénuries de main
d'oeuvre de soignants pourquoi parce
qu'en réalité la population mondiale a
doublé en l'espace de génération nous ne
sommes pas de moins de 4 milliards
d'habitants sur la planète à 8 8
milliards et bientôt 9 milliards
d'habitants
que parmi ces 4 milliards nouveaux il y
a au moins 3 milliards de personnes qui
sont sorties de l'extrême pauvreté et
qui sont devenus des classes moyennes en
Afrique en Asie en Chine en Inde et ces
3 milliards de personnes consomment du
soin alors je sais que quand je dis ça
souvent ça choque parce que le soin
n'est pas une consommation courante mais
c'est comme ça qu'on parle en
macroéconomie de la santé donc il y a
une utilisation des ressources en soins
que ce soit en ressources humaines ou en
médicament
dans de nombreux pays qui jusqu'à
présent ne soignaient pas leur
population parce qu'elle était trop
pauvre et 3 milliards séparents 3 à 4
milliards de personnes en plus à soigner
en deux générations c'est énorme et il
faut ajouter à ça le fait que
la population mondiale a gagné 20 ans de
durée de vie en l'espace de deux
générations et c'est pas vingt ans entre
0 et 20 ans à l'âge on n'a pas besoin de
médicaments c'est 20 ans entre 60 et 80
ans à un moment de la vie où on consomme
des lentilles hypertenseurs des
chimiothérapies etc donc on voit bien
qu'il y a une explosion une
exponentielle des besoins en ressources
humaines et en produit de santé qui n'a
pas été anticipé on n'a pas multiplié
par quatre ou cinq le nombre de médecins
ou d'infirmières formés dans le monde on
n'a pas multiplié par quatre ou cinq le
nombre de chaînes de production des
médicaments et tous ces pays consomment
des antibiotiques des antidouleurs des
chimiothérapies et sont maintenant dans
concurrence en concurrence avec nous
pour l'attractivité pour les industriels
qui font marcher clairement l'offre
la loi de l'offre et de la demande et
qui parfois vont au plus offrant après
on pourra revenir sur la spécificité du
marché français parce que je pense qu'il
y en a une parce que je pense que nous
sommes un des plus beaux marchés au
monde
contrairement à ce que disent parfois
les industriels alors
tout ça pour dire que
la tension est partout que ça
nécessitait énormément d'investissement
dans des chaînes de production nouvelles
partout dans le monde et pas seulement
en Europe et
puis à cela c'est rajouté évidemment
pendant 20 ans la mondialisation qu'on a
souvent rapporté
au coût de la main d'oeuvre
mondialisation qui a amené des
délocalisations en Chine ou en Inde
à cause du coût de la main d'oeuvre mais
en réalité quand on regarde vraiment les
pénuries de médicaments et c'est là où
j'ai réalisé quelque chose de nouveau
pour moi c'est que en fait nos normes
environnementales aujourd'hui en Europe
rend le coup de la chimie et de
l'industrie chimique importante et donc
on a délocalisé notre production
chimique dont la production des
principes actifs en Chine et en Inde en
fait on a délocalisé délocaliser notre
pollution
ce qui est quand même voilà il faut bien
en avoir conscience donc voilà ça c'est
le contexte général avec lequel il faut
faire alors effectivement vous l'avez
rappelé madame la Présidente à la suite
de ce rapport et de groupes de travail
qui concernait qui vraiment réunissait
tous les acteurs c'est-à-dire les
acteurs de la pharmacie les grossistes
restent par titeur les industriels les
associations de malades les soignants
etc nous avons établi cette feuille de
route elle a utilisé la mission
d'information parlementaire elle a
essayé vraiment de de tirer dans tous
les coins pour essayer d'améliorer la
situation en sachant qu'il n'y a pas de
remède miracle qui va du jour au
lendemain
nous permettre de de répondre aux
pénuries même si il y a des solutions
qu'on peut mettre en oeuvre transparence
et informations c'était vraiment pour
anticiper les besoins pour fluidifier
les chaînes de
pour les pharmaciens quand ils sentent
qu'il va y avoir rupture et qu'ils ont
un patient suivi par tel ou tel
médicament malheureusement ce que j'ai
compris
c'est que cette transparence et cette
fluidification de la chaîne n'est pas
encore code totalement
enfin efficience
il y avait ensuite des actions de
prévention et de gestion des circuits
notamment la capacité par les
pharmaciens d'officine de remplacer
automatiquement un produit manquant par
un produit équivalent sur la base de
recommandations de la NSM pour les
médicaments d'intérêt thérapeutique
majeur mais MITM nous avions renforcé
les plans de gestion des pénuries des
PGP des industriels ou des avions obligé
notamment à avoir des stocks pour deux
mois et pour certains produits si les
ruptures étaient amenées à se répéter
nous pouvions nous avions le droit de
leur demander d'augmenter leur stock
pour trois voire quatre mois ou au
contraire de les réduire pour les
médicaments pour lequel il n'y avait pas
de pénurie nous avions réfléchi à des
procédure d'achat et notamment vous
savez que les marchés publics notamment
hospitaliers ont tendance à choisir le
le moins 10 ans sur le plan financier et
donc dans ces achats groupés de
médicaments
à force de choisir ceux qui sont le
moins coûteux à juste titre et bien on
met en difficulté un certain nombre
d'industriels et on s'expose un peu plus
à un risque de pénurie donc voir s'il
n'y avait pas moyen dans la note que
l'on attribue à tel ou tel critère dans
lors de l'attribution d'un marché public
par exemple de vérifier que l'industriel
fabriqué en France par rapport à
fabriquer en dehors de l'Union
c'est-à-dire de prendre d'autres
indicateurs qui permettaient de rendre
la chaîne de production plus robuste et
de nous rendre un peu de souveraineté et
de pas tout miser sur les baisses de
prix
enfin il y avait ce pardon il y avait
ensuite ce troisième
[Musique]
axe qui était le renforcement de la
coordination nationale et surtout
européenne et j'y reviendrai mais je
pense que aujourd'hui la bonne échelle
de travail est une échelle européenne
donc il y avait le renforcement de la
régulation la renforcement de la
connaissance des sites géographiques de
production et des chaînes de production
avec vraiment une cartographie qui
devait être plus robuste que celle qu'on
avait puisque le problème aussi c'est
que ça change c'est-à-dire que une
cartographie elle fixe un paysage à un
moment donné vous savez qui produit quoi
qui a la mm mais un an plus tard le
principe actif a pu être donné à un
autre industriel et en fait cette
cartographie il faut la maintenir à jour
tout le temps au bout de deux trois
quatre ans elle est rapidement obsolète
donc c'est un vrai travail et donc il
nous semblait que le niveau européen
était le bon
renforcement des sanctions y compris
financières pour les industriels qui ne
m'était pas en œuvre des plans de
gestion de risque de qualité
nous voulions préserver des médicaments
anciens et ça c'est quelque chose à
laquelle je t'ai particulièrement
sensible en tant que médecin on sait
qu'en tant que médecin ce qui compte
c'est évidemment l'innovation je ne dis
pas que l'innovation est utile mais ce
qui compte c'est d'avoir un nombre
important de médicaments dans son dans
les possibilités thérapeutiques qu'on
offre aux gens parce qu'il y a des
patients qui répondent mieux à des
médicaments anciens que des médicaments
innovants et donc il faut impérativement
préservé ce que nous avons comme
médicament
utile et ancien et donc l'idée c'était
de tenir compte du coût de revient et du
marché pour établir pour rétablir un
prix pour des médicaments anciens dont
le prix avait été baissé avec le temps
parce qu'ils étaient anciens et qui à la
fin n'était plus du tout intéressant à
produire pour des industriels avec un
marché trop petit trop peu de malade et
donc l'idée était vraiment de
retravailler sur ces médicaments les
plus anciens pour les préserver et les
garder disponible
nous avions demandé à conduire une
une mission sur une solution publique de
production de médicaments je vous avais
cité tout à l'heure dans mon expérience
professionnelle la Pharmacie centrale
des hôpitaux de Paris qui est un
établissement pharmaceutique il y en a
d'autres il y a pas mal de pays de Chu
qui sont en capacité de produire des
médicaments
faut pas se leurrer ils sont capables de
produire au coût parcours en cas de
pénurie quand on se répète ils sont pas
capables de tout régler quand on est à
1000 ou 2000 médicaments manquants
surtout que un certain nombre de
médicaments deviennent assez compliqués
à produire notamment tous les
médicaments de biothérapie ce qu'on
appelle biothérapie c'est tout ce qui
passe par de la génétique
ce sont des médicaments qui ne se
produisent pas dans une pharmacie
centrale voilà donc il y a quand même
des limites à cette idée d'un pôle
public le hameau qui est cher à Madame
la rapporteur Paul public des
médicaments mais si je crois qu'il en
faut un évidemment mon idée c'est plutôt
qu'il soit au niveau européen puisque
tous les pays européens ont absolument
la même difficulté et que on définit
exactement quels sont les capacités
il est illusoire d'imaginer qu'un peu le
public puisse remplacer l'industrie
pharma aujourd'hui l'industrie pharmace
sont des milliers et des milliers
d'usines de savoir-faire voilà c'est
c'est
je pense que la complexité aujourd'hui
d'un certain nombre de productions rend
les choses un peu illusoire mais il ne
faut pas abandonner cette piste je ne
pense pas que l'échelle d'un pays soit
le bon vous dire pourquoi
la France aujourd'hui je crois qu'il
faut en être conscient nous faisons la
taille de deux villes chinoises
c'est ça la taille de la France nous
sommes 67 millions d'habitants les
nouvelles villes chinoises elles font 30
millions c'est-à-dire que il faut qu'on
se donne les moyens
d'être
je dirais compétitif et à mon avis
l'échelle européenne 300 millions
d'habitants c'est une échelle où on peut
être en face à face avec les Big Pharma
avec des industriels qui ont des
monopoles sur des produits et qui sont
des industries mondialisées en dessous
de cette échelle ça devient le bras de
fer est assez compliqué
dans le se renforcement
de la coordination européenne on avait
prévu des achats groupés aussi européens
pour essayer de réduire les compétitions
entre États européens parce que il y en
a il ne faut pas se leurrer aujourd'hui
les étages cherchent à attirer des
produits et certains États sont prêts à
mettre plus d'argent sur la table on l'a
vu pendant le covid madame la Présidente
certains pays n'hésitez pas à aller
acheter des masques sur le tarmac c'est
pareil pour les médicaments certains
pays n'ont absolument pas de voilà de
difficultés à cela et
je reviendrai sur le marché français
mais le Français ne marche chez français
et il a quand même cette
particularité c'est que c'est un marché
ou 100% des malades qui ont besoin d'un
médicament ont accès à un médicament
innovant je crois qu'on est un des seuls
pays au monde où 100% des citoyens ont
accès à l'innovation et remboursé et
donc on n'est pas dans la même situation
que beaucoup de marchés européens ou en
fait une fraction de la population
seulement accède à des médicaments
voilà le quatrième axe c'était la
gouvernance de tout cela donc l'idée
c'était que la NSM soit quand même au
centre du jeu c'est eux qui connaissent
les importations qui connaissent les
stocks et donc on avait lancé un comité
de pilotage que j'avais tenu le premier
copie comité de pilotage c'était tenu au
ministère de la Santé le 23 septembre
2019 et en parallèle de cette feuille de
route qui visait à essayer vraiment
d'améliorer la situation partout on
avait un levier d'action au niveau
national
nous avions confié c'était une mission
du Premier ministre mais je pense que
vous avez dû en entendre parler nous
avions confié à Jacques bio qui est
ancien président de l'école
polytechnique et qui avait beaucoup été
conseillé auprès d'industriels du
médicament
une mission sur les aspects purement
industriels pas sur les aspects
distribution pas sur les aspects
recommandations mais vraiment comment
travailler avec les industriels pour
régler ses pénuries
chaque bio devait nous rendre un rapport
en janvier 2020 je pense qu'il a rendu
en janvier 2020 je n'ai pas le souvenir
de l'avoir lu à l'époque même si je fais
partie le 15 février peut-être qu'il
circulait déjà dans mon cabinet mais en
tous les cas moi je n'ai pas le souvenir
de l'avoir vu mais bon c'était une
époque où j'étais j'étais beaucoup Sénat
pour la loi de Beauty
je m'occupais de la réforme des
retraites aussi et j'étais quand même
assez occupée donc peut-être qu'il était
sur mon bureau mais je n'ai pas lu en
tous les cas avant mon départ voilà ça
c'est pour les actions en tant que
ministre
maintenant vous me demandez des
solutions je suis prête à en discuter
avec vous mais je pense que des
questions autour de du médicament sont
en fait plus vastes que simplement les
pénuries
nous en convenons bien volontiers même
si l'objectif de cette commission c'est
quand même de
répondre à la question des pénuries qui
va s'aggraver et qui ne semble et qui
sont fort loin d'être endigués je passe
tout de suite la parole à Madame la
rapporteur lance Cohen pour une première
série de questions je vous remercie
merci madame la ministre pour la
sincérité de vos propos et la synthèse
aussi parce que c'est un exercice qui
est qui est difficile donc je vais vous
poser un certain nombre de questions
pour vous permettre peut-être d'aller
plus loin dans les explications que vous
avez pu nous apporter et puis nous aussi
de mieux maîtriser les choses alors vous
l'avez dit entre 2008 et 2018 le nombre
des pénuries qui a été signalé par
l'Agence nationale de sécurité qui a été
signalée pardon à l'Agence nationale de
sécurité du médicament a été multipliée
par 20 vous avez présenté donc une
feuille de route en 2010 qui faisait
2019-202022 donc réuni 128 mesures pour
lutter contre ces pénuries est-ce que à
votre connaissance ces travaux ont été
ralentis voire suspendus pendant la
crise sanitaire
et à l'époque comment ces mesures
avaient-elles été reçues par la
l'ensemble des acteurs qui sont
impliqués je pense aux industriels au
distributeurs aux pharmaciens etc donc
ça c'est ma première question ma
deuxième ma deuxième question vous avez
vous aviez fait d'ailleurs vous l'avez
vous l'avez signalé un axe majeur de la
transparence et de l'exhaustivité de
l'information sur les ruptures
d'approvisionnement et cette ambition
aujourd'hui et d'ailleurs vous l'avez
dit paraît largement inachevé donc
pourquoi est-ce qu'il n'a pas été
possible d'agir plus rapidement à ce
sujet et quels sont les points de
blocage que vous avez pu
identifier
ma troisième question c'est
l'objectif donc de prévenir plus plus
efficacement les pénuries de médicaments
puisque ça n'est pas un phénomène
nouveau mais c'est un phénomène qui va
qui va s'amplifier donc n'apparaît pas
aujourd'hui rempli on en convient tous
est-ce que les difficultés qui ont été
rencontrées notamment cet hiver dans un
contexte particulier avec une résurgence
épidémique prévisible mais mais en même
temps
difficile
est-ce que donc face à ces difficultés
vous pouvez vous tirer un premier bilan
de la mise en oeuvre de la feuille de
route durant durant vos fonctions
puisque il y a il y a vraiment tout ça
c'est très mêlé et finalement quels sont
les axes sur lesquels des efforts
supplémentaires doivent être déployés
selon vous pour mieux prévenir et gérer
les pénuries sont des questions donc qui
ont vraiment très haut pénurie vous avez
parlé
de de la mise en place de sanctions
financières il en a effectivement été
question lors de nos auditions en nous
interrogeant sur peut-être le besoin de
les renforcer mais également en nous
interrogeant sur le fait que l'Agence
nationale de sécurité du médicament
avait je crois signifié trois ou quatre
sanctions financières donc ça paraît
totalement
infime par rapport à la réalité ma
quatrième question c'est plus sur les
stocks et la pandémie de covid-19
on l'a dit au début de la pandémie la
question de la gestion des stocks de
masques à soulever vraiment de très
lourdes interrogations notamment quand
aux raisons de la destruction de
plusieurs milliers d'entre eux ou le
dépassement de la date de péremption
pareil quels enseignements en tirez-vous
alors évidemment trop toute proportion
gardée mais pour la constitution de
stocks de médicaments critiques parce
que je pense que quand même il y a un
élément à relever bien souvent il y a
des politiques qui sont menées au niveau
des différents ministères enfin des
différents ministres plutôt de la santé
suivre aussi d'ailleurs dans d'autres
secteurs et rarement on en tire les
bilans et les enseignements pour
corriger les politiques à venir donc
voilà ça c'est une autre question ma
cinquième question c'est sur la
transparence
en mai 2019 il y a eu une résolution de
l'OMS qui a été adoptée à l'unanimité
sur la transparence concernant les prix
des médicaments et en novembre 2019 vous
avez été destinataire avec le Premier
ministre une lettre ouverte signée par
plus de 70 organisations et
personnalités demandant visage de
transparence dans les politiques du
médicament or j'étais surprise de
constater que la France avait mis du
temps pour soutenir cette résolution de
l'OMS donc j'aimerais que vous puissiez
nous dire pourquoi il y a eu une
nécessité de ce temps et il m'a pas
semblé que vous aviez été facilitatrice
dans dans l'adoption de de cette de
cette résolution
alors c'est vrai que nous avons eu
notamment au Sénat le vote je crois
c'est pas l'unanimité c'est la majorité
d'un amendement donc allant cette
direction il y a eu le conseil c'est le
Conseil constitutionnel
qui avait rejeté pour des raisons assez
formelles mais vous aviez la possibilité
en tant que ministre de pouvoir dépasser
je dirais ce blocage en agissant au
niveau réglementaire donc pourquoi vous
n'avez pas
fait cette cet acte comme ça avait été
fait en Italie ça c'est une question que
nous nous posons et d'ailleurs que se
pose également l'Observatoire de la
transparence des politiques
en matière de médicaments la dernière
question que je voudrais vous poser
c'est celle
vous concernant par rapport aux grands
laboratoire dans l'ouvrage chantage sur
ordonnance comment les labos vides les
caisses de la Sécu la journaliste
rosette de Lucin interroge le
financement public de l'industrie
pharmaceutique pour des résultats quasi
nuls l'auteur rapporte vos propos qui
exprimeraient je vais employer le
conditionnel même si vous êtes cité
entre guillemets une indignation
concernant les aides et la difficulté
pour pour le ministère de la Santé de
résister à cette pression
des des grands des grands labos donc
il y a des aides publiques extrêmement
importantes qui sont délivrées au grand
laboratoire pour un résultat donc minime
ou minimaliste on l'a vu au moment de la
covid avec les vaccins
vous vous en êtes
insurgé je vais dire vous vous êtes
insurgé contre ça comment donc on peut
travailler pour faire en sorte que les
investissements publics ne soient pas
dévoyés et répondent réellement aux
besoins des populations et du coup la
j'ouvre peut-être sur quelque chose que
vous n'avez pas abordé c'est à dire des
propositions que l'on pourrait faire
parce que au niveau de notre notre
commission on n'est pas seulement dans
l'état des lieux on est aussi dans les
propositions vous avez parlé du pôle
public du du médicament c'est une
proposition qui a été rejetée ici en le
9 décembre 2020 mais sans aller jusqu'au
pôle public du médicament vous avez
donné comme exemple la Pharmacie
centrale nous on a auditionné la geppes
aujourd'hui lajeps n'a même n'a plus les
moyens même qui pouvaient y avoir en
2018 2019 etc de fabriquer des
médicaments donc ils ont ils ont recours
à
des
entreprises pour le pour le faire dans
un partenariat public privé donc il y a
des choses qui sont possibles à faire
donc c'est possible en temps de crise
est-ce que ça ne serait pas possible sur
une liste restreinte de médicaments
critiques qui comporteraient 50 au
maximum peut-être 100 médicaments mais
qui permettrait d'avoir effectivement de
reprendre un peu la souveraineté pour la
France voilà merci beaucoup désolé
beaucoup de questions mais c'est vrai
que nous avons besoin de beaucoup de
réponses aussi madame la ministre vous
avez la parole
merci madame la présidente Madame la
rapporteur je vais essayer de voilà de
suivre le déroulé de vos questions qui
sont effectivement nombreuses donc votre
première question
était y a-t-il eu un ralentissement de
la mise en oeuvre de la feuille de route
pendant le covid à l'évidence oui comme
à peu près tous les plans que j'ai fait
à cette période là que ce soit ma santé
2022 où le plan de rénovation des
urgences de refondation des urgences je
dirais que tout s'est arrêté quasiment
net en février 2019 avec les choses ont
repris petit à petit et que entre-temps
beaucoup d'acteurs ont changé et c'est
donc c'est très difficile de s'inscrire
dans une continuité
avec je dirais un délai de 1 2 3 ans ou
pas grand chose n'a pu se passer des
facto et avec des changements de
ministres d'administration centrale
voilà et ces politiques publiques à des
millent même certains plans ont même été
oubliés parce que les acteurs ont changé
donc voilà je je pense que que ça
explique notamment le fait que toute la
partie sur la transparence puisque vous
en parliez n'a pratiquement avant pas
avancé en tous les cas c'est ce que j'ai
vu en préparant un petit peu cette
commission d'enquête avant de venir vous
voir parce que j'ai justement voulu voir
où on était le plan et il semblerait que
voilà des il n'y a pas les outils
informatiques
tout ça est quand même assez compliqué à
mettre en oeuvre puisque le nombre
d'acteurs impliqués dans la chaîne de
production et de distribution et
considérable entre les grossistes
répartiteurs les pharmaciens d'officine
des prescripteurs les agences
réglementaires les industriels et que
pour chaque médicament cette chaîne peut
varier donc avoir une traçabilité
complète de la chaîne avec autant
d'acteurs et quand même assez complexe
je pense que ça peut expliquer le retard
prix ensuite vous demandez comment la
feuille de route a été reçue
elle avait été travaillé par tout le
monde donc je dirais que on était arrivé
à consensus même si la question des
stocks avait quand même posé pas mal de
problèmes aux industriels et la question
des sanctions n'en parlons pas bon on
voit l'arrivée que les sanctions n'ont
pas été nombreuses donc il y avait pas
de raison d'avoir peur mais en tous les
cas où cette partie là n'a pas été très
bien reçue j'ai le souvenir de quelques
tensions
ensuite le bilan le bilan
malheureusement je ne peux regarder que
ce que je vois dans la presse et à
l'évidence la situation c'est pas
améliorée en termes de pénurie et sur
des médicaments d'intérêt thérapeutique
majeurs donc c'est très inquiétant mais
je ne suis pas sûr que cette feuille de
route répondait à la racine du mal la
feuille de route elle répond aux
conséquences mais la racine du mal c'est
le manque d'industrialisation c'est la
délocalisation c'est des principes
actifs centralisés fabriqués en Chine et
je suis pas sûr aujourd'hui que
l'industrie pharmaceutique se soit mis à
construire des usines de production
principe actifs d'en Union européenne
pour les raisons normaux
environnementales dont je parlais moi
j'ai le souvenir
d'avoir eu
d'avoir voulu fermer une usine de Sanofi
qu'il fabriquait de la dépakine dans le
sud-ouest de la France pour des raisons
de pollution et de rejets et au moment
où vraiment je voulais mettre en oeuvre
cela j'ai compris que ce site de
production produisait 98% de la dépakine
mondiale il y a énormément d'enfants
épileptiques ou de gens épileptiques qui
n'ont pas d'autres médicaments de
substitution donc vous êtes pris entre
le marteau et l'Enclus entre les normes
environnementales et et bon et vous
n'avez pas les moyens non plus
financiers d'obliger des industriels et
tous les industriels à doubler tripler
leur chaîne de production donc quelque
part la fête de route fallait pas on
peut pas non plus en attendre
un miracle quand on voit quelle est la
racine du mal qui est quand même le
problème industriel de fond derrière de
délocalisation
massive et de besoins qui ont triplé
voire cadreplay en terme de consommation
dans le monde dans les 10 dernières
années donc c'est mondial et c'est pour
ça que je dis pour moi la solution de
cette question de souveraineté
elle doit se traiter au niveau Européen
parce que nous avons tous les mêmes
problèmes et que c'est pas la peine de
nous d'être en compétition les uns avec
les autres pour mettre plus d'argent sur
la table pour essayer d'attirer les
médicaments quand il y a une pénurie ce
que c'est ça aujourd'hui que je vous les
industriels et ça ça n'est pas tolérable
on peut pas sous prétexte que
l'Allemagne ou l'Italie va payer un peu
plus
et pour éviter cela je pense que les
mesures doivent être des achats groupés
et surtout des productions voire des
pôles publiques à l'échelon européen et
pas les champions français parce que
quand même la production d'un médicament
ce n'est pas un métier comme un autre
c'est soumis à de très grosses normes
des règles de qualité notamment qui sont
assurés par un laboratoire situé dans au
sein du Conseil de l'Europe qui
s'appelle le Directoire la direction
européenne de qualité des médicaments et
de la santé c'est une structure qui je
crois en 400 personnes situées au
Conseil de l'Europe à Strasbourg
qui est en charge de la qualité et de
mise en œuvre des normes je suis pas sûr
que vous en ayez beaucoup entendu parler
parce que moi-même comme mini je n'en ai
pas entendu parler or il existe une
grosse structure européenne
administrative qui évalue la qualité des
actifs en Europe et c'est le Conseil de
l'Europe donc c'est bien plus large que
l'Union européenne et la Russie voilà il
y a d'autres pays je pense que ça
vaudrait le coup de voir ce qu'ils sont
capables aussi de faire pour aider à
lutter contre cette pénurie et je crois
qu'il y a un site délocalisé à Metz il
me semble
donc
[Musique]
après vous me demandez quels axes
supplémentaires je reviendrai peut-être
parce que ça rejoint votre question
finale sur sur les industriels sanctions
financière est-ce qu'elles sont
suffisantes
je pense qu'à l'évidence elle ne font
pas suffisamment peur et elles ne sont
pas
ça n'est pas une motivation suffisante
aujourd'hui pour que les industriels et
je ne pense pas qu'une sanction
financière à l'échelle de la France
et la moindre capacité à faire changer
des politiques industrielles ou de
distribution de médicaments qui sont
pour la grande majorité des produits
décidaient aux US parce que les sièges
de la plupart des Big Pharma sont
américains et parfois il traite les
sièges français avec beaucoup de
d'éloignement voire de mes prix donc
c'est la raison vraiment pour laquelle
j'ai du mal à imaginer une solution pour
moi française en réalité vu l'ampleur du
problème et vu la racine du problème
alors ensuite vous m'avezardez des
stocks pendant les covids alors je vais
peut-être pas refaire ici toute
l'histoire des masques sauf que depuis
la commission d'enquête parlementaire
j'ai beaucoup repris en fait toute
l'historique des masques je serais ravie
un jour d'en parler avec vous mais en
fait toute cette destruction des masques
avait été totalement programmée elle
était totalement connue des des de santé
publique France elle avait été décidé en
2013 la fin des stocks était décidée
pour 2015 donc bien avant que j'arrive
les masques périmés les
pour toujours pour
usage d'être détruit donc c'était
quelque chose une politique de
destruction qui était classique à santé
publique France donc il y avait rien
quelque part d'anormal dans ce qu'on a
eu mais ce qu'on a subi en fait de plein
fouet ça rejoint complètement votre
commission aujourd'hui c'est que en fait
toute la stratégie mise en place par mes
prédécesseurs en 2011 et 2013 et à la
suite de la crise H1 on avait beaucoup
hurlé sur les stocks trop importants la
plupart des rapports avec la même pointé
du doigt la gamme j financière etc donc
mes prédécesseurs avaient pris des
décisions de faire des stocks tournants
c'est remis dans le circuit
régulièrement pour éviter justement les
péremptions ce que ce que d'un point de
vue logistique santé publique France
avait du mal à mettre en oeuvre et des
stocks tampons c'est quoi un stock
tampon c'est à dire on enfin à l'époque
les les gouvernements qui avaient pris
ses décisions en 2011 et 2013 elle est
dit plutôt que d'avoir des stocks de
milliards de produits de santé qu'on ne
sait pas gérer parce que ça ça
représente des entrepôts de type Amazon
c'est de la logistique on va faire des
stocks pour un mois en attendant les
commandes et donc on se met en état
d'attendre des commandes sauf que ce que
personne n'avait anticipé à l'époque je
pense c'est que même s'il y avait des
productions importantes dans différents
pays quand j'étais importante
même s'il y avait plusieurs sites de
production
de masse ou de documents de protection
en Europe en fait personne n'avait
réalisé que les matières premières qui
servent à fabriquer des masques était
toute fabriquées à One et dans la région
de Roubaï donc au moment où on a
commandé des masses puisque moi j'ai
lancé mes premières commandes le 24
janvier one venait d'être fermé par des
chinois et donc en fait ils n'ont pas
exporté les matières premières et ça je
crois que personne n'avait tiré le fil
jusqu'au bout et c'est exactement ce
qu'on a avec les pénuries de médicament
principe actif délocalisé dans une usine
en Chine et le monde entier en paie le
prix en fait pour le masque était pareil
sauf que personne n'était au courant et
donc personne n'avait anticipé des
besoins de stock bien supérieurs par
ailleurs et je le regrette parce que
personne n'a vraiment tiré le fil
jusqu'au bout de ce qu'il aurait fallu
comme stock de masse pour tenir un
manque contrairement à ce qu'on dit ça
n'est pas un milliards mais c'est 4
milliards parce que la consommation
était d'un milliard par semaine pourquoi
ça n'avait pas été envisagé parce qu'il
n'y a jamais eu jamais aucune
recommandation au monde jusqu'à ce que
l'OMS change sa recommandation en juin
2000 20 de port du masque en population
générale donc de toute façon tous les
calculs avaient été fait pour stocker
des masques pour les soignants et les
malades et ça ça n'avait jamais
évidemment abouti un stock d'un milliard
donc en réalité tous les problèmes ont
été mélangés je ne reviendrai pas sur la
complexité de cette crise mais elle est
liée à deux faites premièrement que
jamais personne n'avait envisagé qu'il
fallait des masques en population
générale et que ça n'a été créé dans
aucune recommandation au monde j'ai fait
toute la littérature sur le sujet pour
l'accord de justice de la République
donc je peux vous dire que je mets au
défi qui que ce soit de trouver une
recommandation différente et
deuxièmement
personne n'avait envisagé que la
totalité des matières premières pour les
produits de protection étaient faites
dans la région de Dubaï qui allait être
fermée parce que c'était l'épicentre
d'une épidémie c'est-à-dire comme
malchance vous voyez si cette matière
première avait été fabriquée en
Thaïlande aux États-Unis nous n'aurions
pas eu cette même de commando alors
beaucoup de choses qui se sont
concentrées à ce moment-là mais en fait
sa pointe exactement la difficulté que
nous subissons aujourd'hui avec les
Pinière médicament et la nécessité d'une
souveraineté et c'est là où j'en reviens
au fait que
malheureusement nous avons une mémoire
courte tous parce que pour les masques
comme pour les pénuries de médicaments
on a vu qu'on avait relancé la
production de masques en France pendant
la crise covid et puis on a vu
progressivement que les prix de
production étant chair et bien
progressivement les hôpitaux ont arrêté
d'acheter les producteurs français ils
ont fait faillite et on est reparti sur
des masques fabriqués je ne sais où donc
c'est c'est là où je
je pense qu'il y a il y a quand même
dans les solutions quand même la prise
en compte dans les critères d'achat
notamment de nos établissements publics
des prises en compte de critères de
souveraineté ça je crois un
impérativement qu'on ne peut pas
toujours avoir le prix comme critère
principal de choix d'un prestataire pour
les hôpitaux bon après ça coûte cher et
évidemment ça nécessite peut-être des
moyens financiers supplémentaires
[Musique]
alors
sur la transparence
[Musique]
la transparence sur le prix des
médicaments alors je vais être
parfaitement honnête avec vous vous
l'avez compris je pense que vous avez vu
mon interview par cette journaliste dans
ce livre ça fait des années en fait que
je suis
quelque part
la garante
de la qualité des soins et des prix des
médicaments de par mes fonctions
antérieures et donc ça fait des années
que je suis quelque part un peu en
bisbille avec l'industrie pharmaceutique
et la méchante je joue le rôle de la
méchante donc je pense qu'on ne peut pas
voilà on ne peut pas me retirer le fait
que j'ai toujours œuvré pour que les
patients français soient bien soignés et
que cela ne coûte pas des milliards à la
Sécurité sociale parce que j'estime
avoir suffisamment d'arguments
scientifiques pour être en capacité de
contrer certaines façons de procéder des
industriels qui m'ont heurté dans tous
les postes que j'ai pu occuper je
voudrais dire d'ailleurs que en 2015 ou
2016 je n'ai plus la date exacte lorsque
le G7 était au Japon
François Hollande était à l'époque
président de la République j'étais
président de l'Institut National du
Cancer je lui avais fait une note pour
le à inscrire au G7 des ministres de la
santé la question du prix des
médicaments anticancéreux je les voyais
arriver je voyais arriver
l'immunothérapie avec des coûts
exorbitants pour la sécurité sociale
j'avais déjà la ferme conviction que la
France seule n'était pas incapable de
réguler ses prix que si nous voulions
pouvoir soigner tous les malades
contrairement à ce que fait l'Angleterre
qui défacto ne donne pas l'accès à
beaucoup de médicaments trop onéreux
nous nous assurons l'accès à
l'innovation pour tous mais il faut
quand même s'assurer aussi que la
sécurité sociale peut emporter le prix
j'avais donc convaincu François Hollande
de porter cette question de prix des
médicaments au G7 je ne sais pas ce qui
s'est passé derrière je crois que c'est
rien passé mais mon idée c'était qu'il
faut qu'on revienne sur le mode de
fixation du prix des médicaments
face aux industriels je pense que
aujourd'hui
nous sommes dans une échelle de
perroquet
qui n'a plus de sens c'est quoi des
chefs de perroquet c'est à chaque fois
que vous avez un médicament innovant je
vais répondre à votre question je l'ai
pas oublié mais il faut que vous
compreniez quel est mon arrière-pensée
vous avez à chaque fois que vous avez un
médicament innovant si la porte le
moindre bénéfice thérapeutique par
rapport à un médicament existant
l'industriel a le droit d'avoir un prix
supérieur aux médicaments de référence
existant
cette politique de fixation du prix elle
date des années 70 où on voulait
promouvoir l'innovation et faire en
sorte que les industriels investissent
dans l'innovation et produisent des
médicaments plus performants
40 ans après
l'innovation a été très importante
notamment en cancérologie et donc vous
avez une accélération de l'innovation et
avec cette échelle de perroquet
aujourd'hui vous payez des médicaments
qui apportent trois mois de vie en plus
l'équivalent de 100000 dollars alors que
trois mois de vie gagné en plus il y a
10 ans c'était 8000 euros donc en fait
cette échelle de perroquet fait à chaque
fois vous montez le prix quel que soit
le bénéfice et donc quand vous mettez
côte à côte l'innovation des années 2000
avec l'innovation des années 2020 et
bien pour trois mois de vie gagné en
plus vous avez quintuplé voire multiplié
par 10 le prix que vous êtes capable de
enfin le prix que vous accordez à ce
bénéfice thérapeutique de par cette
fixation de du prix et cette échelle de
perroquet qui est dans la loi en fait
donc et elle apporte en fait des
inégalités invraisemblables parce que
comme l'innovation est très importante
en cancérologie vous accordez au prix la
vie en cancérologie des sommes de la
sécurité sociale faramineuses et vous
payez pas du tout autant d'argent pour
des patients diabétiques aujourd'hui ne
serait-ce que parce que l'innovation n'a
pas été suffisante pour que cette
échelle de prix augmente aussi vite
qu'en cancero et donc vous regardez un
an de vie gagnez en cancero ou un nom de
gagner dans une autre pathologie ça n'a
rien à voir en terme de d'effort fournis
par la collectivité ça pose problème moi
je l'ai souvent dit aux associations de
patients vous devriez vous préoccuper
quand même de l'équité de ce qu'on
dépense et donc pour moi tout ça
nécessite impérativement que l'on revoit
la politique du prix de la fixation du
prix vis-à-vis des industriels mais là
encore la France seule ne peut rien
c'est à l'échelon européen qu'on peut
négocier des prix vous savez qu'il y a
ce qu'on appelle le corridor européen
qui fait que les cinq pays principaux
l'Allemagne Italie l'Espagne la France
et il m'en manquait j'ai oublié
l'Angleterre mais elle est plus là mais
mais l'Angleterre
en gros sont tenus à avoir des
l'équivalent même si après les
réductions de coûts qui sont discutées
par derrière peuvent varier mais en gros
vous êtes un peu tenu par ce corridor
européen et par le prix de fixation par
le préfixé par les Américains donc en
fait on est pieds et points liés dans la
fixation du prix
et aujourd'hui
comment est-ce que les pays européens
négocient les baisses de de coûts et
bien c'est en négociant des des
réversions
qui sont qui ne sont pas transparentes
alors pourquoi je me suis pas engagée
sur cette transparence du prix du
médicament bon c'est très politique
c'est pour moi c'est un slogan mais pour
moi ça n'a absolument pas de valeur
utile c'est-à-dire je trouvais que
c'était pas comme ça qu'on allait
réduire comme ça qu'on avait réglé le
problème
le problème de la transparence c'est
qu'on risquait de se priver
des seuls moyens qu'on a de réduire les
coûts qui sont les remises qu'on fait
par derrière et donc plus on est
transparent plus on se plie encore plus
les points et pour négocier avec les
industriel pour que la sécurité sociale
ne dépense pas des fortunes parce qu'en
réalité il y a un prix faciale qui lui
est transparent mais si vous
rendez la négo transparente mais à ce
moment-là vous êtes en difficulté par
rapport aux autres pays européens et
vous risquez de ne plus pouvoir négocier
avec des industriels donc en fait je
pense que c'était évidemment je voyais
bien
l'objectif mais je trouvais qu'il ne
servait pas en tous les cas pour moi
ministre mon souhait qui était de
réduire les coûts au maximum voilà c'est
en ça que je n'ai pas poussé et c'est un
slogan politique comme la Phano brevet
etc c'est de la politique mais à un
moment est-ce qu'on cherche la politique
ou est-ce qu'on cherche l'efficience
c'est probablement un de mes défauts
c'est que souvent je cherche
l'efficience plus que la politique je
l'avais fait plus de politique peut-être
que je m'en serais mieux portée mais bon
voilà c'est c'est la raison de du fait
que j'ai pas embrayé sur cette question
transparence et que je porte ce que je
portais déjà à l'époque dans ma note à
François Hollande en 2015 c'est que il
faut qu'on ait une politique de
négociation du prix à l'échelle
européenne voilà c'est le seul c'est la
seule échelle où nous sommes capables
d'avoir un bras de fer avec les
industriels
nous sommes sinon nous sommes trop
faibles
ensuite vous me parliez des des
financements publics oui les labos ont
beaucoup de financements publics ne
serait-ce que le crédit pour recherche
puis tout ce qu'on met aujourd'hui dans
la recherche fondamentale puisque
aujourd'hui l'industrie pharmaceutique
investir relativement peu dans la R&D
elle rachète des biotech or les biotech
elles sont issues de la recherche
fondamentale
donc là je pense qu'on pourrait demander
un peu plus de retour sur investissement
voilà et sur la GEPS j'ai pas d'idée
madame la rapporteur parce que je n'ai
pas suivi
dernièrement le financement de la
Pharmacie centrale des hôpitaux
merci beaucoup en Alain le ministre je
vais passer la parole à mes collègues
donc successivement à la Milan Laurence
harribé Corinne Imbert et myéliane
pomirol pour une série de questions et
j'ajouterai une petite question à cet
ensemble à Lamine
ça marche comme ça
on appuie sur ce bouton ça marche
madame la ministre merci pour l'ensemble
des informations que vous venez de nous
donner qui sont comme d'habitude
toujours excellentes je voudrais moi
vous rejoindre sur l'Europe je pense que
en effet on ne peut pas faire autrement
que travailler à partir de l'Union
européenne pour obtenir sur les prix
mais sur beaucoup d'autres choses aussi
en particulier sur l'analyse des
nouveaux médicaments est-ce qu'il est
utile que l'agence européenne donne son
avis sur un nouveau médicament et
qu'ensuite la NSM puis la HAS redonne le
même avis avant qu'on puisse libérer le
médicament au niveau de sa production et
de sa vente sur le territoire national
je vous rejoins aussi sur les les
je voulais vous dire deux secondes je
suis un petit peu confus sur le Conseil
de l'Europe je suis j'ai été désigné par
le président du Sénat membre du Conseil
de l'Europe en tant que parlementaire je
jamais entendu parler de ce que vous
venez de nous dire alors il serait
intéressant et ça je dis à Madame la
rapporteur la présidente qu'on puisse
les consulter parce que c'est vraiment
intéressant ce que vous venez de dire ça
fait trois ans que j'y suis j'avais
jamais entendu parler pour ce qui est
des médicaments innovants
je voudrais juste revenir sur le fait
que en effet il coûte très cher je suis
d'accord avec vous mais s'ils apportent
trois mois de vie de plus au cancéreux
actuel ne vont-ils pas apporter de 3 ou
4 années de plus au Conseil futur c'est
une question qu'on pourrait se poser et
qui n'est pas inutile je voulais surtout
revenir sur des propos que j'ai pu tenir
et qui ont été mal interprétés
sur les stocks de masques d'abord parce
que il y a eu un rapport qui avait été
fait par le Sénat sur h1na dont le
rapporteur était françois Autain le
président de la commission d'enquête
était à la Milan or cette commission
d'enquête à l'époque n'avait pas accusé
la ministre d'avoir trop dépensé au
contraire elle avait demandé à ce que
les Prusse qui existait à l'époque
fastent nécessaire pour que les stocks
de masque ou de médicaments comme le
Tamiflu à l'époque soit mis en réserve
de manière à pouvoir les utiliser en cas
de crise malheureusement
malheureusement avant vous
les Prusse a été supprimé
l'InVS a été supprimé l'impès a été
supprimé au profit de santé publique
France et nous les parlementaires nous
n'avons plus vous aussi d'ailleurs en
tant que ministre nous n'avons plus vu
ce qui se passait à l'intérieur de ces
anciens organismes pour avoir une vision
beaucoup plus grande de santé publique
France mais sans entrer sans pouvoir
entrer dans le détail et c'est un vrai
problème pour les stocks en particulier
et ma question est la suivante
plutôt que de parler de pénurie de
médicaments en particulier cette année
paracétamol et antibiotique ne peut-on
pas essayer de dire qu'il faut faire en
sorte de moins utiliser ces médicaments
faisons attention à l'antibio résistance
qui peut arriver qui peut arriver et en
mettant en place une obligation de port
de masque dans les périodes épidémiques
quand vous avez mis en place
le confinement
nous avons constaté quoi une diminution
quasiment une disparition de la grippe
de la bronchiolite et dès qu'il y a plus
de masque et lavage des mains bien sûr
dès qu'il y a plus de masse on voit quoi
une augmentation considérable de la
grippe et de la bronchiolite alors le
lavage des mains et les masques ne
serait-il pas suffisant à condition
qu'il soit obligatoire en particulier
dans les transports en commun pour
éviter une pénurie d'antibiotique et de
paracétamol
merci beaucoup
Laurence arrivet donc je j'attire votre
attention sur le comment dire vision un
peu plus condensée des questions puisque
nous avons les usagers dans la foulée
merci madame la Présidente merci madame
la ministre pour ces propos vraiment
passionnants et éclairant et c'est drôle
comme quand on quitte la fonction on
devient beaucoup plus transparent
je voudrais je voudrais simplement
revenir sur sur quelque chose que j'ai
pas compris dans la dans ce que vous
avez dit sur la question européenne et
l'importance de la négociation
européenne à laquelle on peut on peut
souscrire mais est-ce que d'abord la
question des prix des médicaments c'est
une compétence de des états c'est pas
une compétence européenne donc est-ce
que vous vous iriez jusqu'à
une transformation enfin une
modification de la compétence ou pas et
ensuite j'ai pas bien compris parce que
vous dites il faut il faut négocier au
niveau européen mais en même temps vous
êtes sceptique sur ou dubitative en tout
cas sur la question de la transparence
en disant si on est trop transparent on
pourra pas avoir des politiques de
rabais et je trouve qu'il y a une
contradiction c'est à dire que comment
peut-on élaborer des prix ou avoir se
donner le rapport de force au niveau
européen pour avoir des prix pour
ensuite après avoir une politique de de
rabais voilà une question très très très
courte mais les autres elles ont été
posées par Alain donc je reviendrai pas
dessus
Corinne Imbert
merci à la présidente merci madame la
ministre pour votre éclairage
peut-être une une remarque vous avez
évoqué la complexité de la chaîne du
médicament ça fabrication d'un site à un
autre etc pour autant j'ai l'impression
que la traçabilité du médicament en tout
cas quand elle arrive dans les officines
en France elle a quand même la
logistique est assez bien huilée et la
traçabilité est également bien bien
organisée elle est d'autant plus avec la
règle sur la sérialisation donc est-ce
que de votre place vous avez observé des
failles dans cette chaîne ou est-ce
qu'au contraire c'est plutôt quand même
correctement ce qui mon sentiment
correctement huilé dans la mesure où on
n'a pas un trafic de faux médicament en
France très important ça c'était une
remarque une question
j'en viens au prix est-ce que dans votre
fonction de ministre de la Santé j'ai
bien entendu
est-ce qu'il vous êtes pas arrivé entre
quatre yeux avec un homologue un de vos
homologues ministres de la santé dans un
pays de l'Union européenne de lui
demander mais combien tu achètes ce
médicament excusez-moi pour le
tutoiement je me mets en situation
bien évidemment je me permettrai pas
mais à un moment donné j'ai du mal à
imaginer
sans forcément tout lâcher
sur les remises etc mais à un moment
donné ce que vous avez pas eu ce genre
de discussion pour avoir un regard et
enfin
je vais devenir plus taquine qu'elle a
mis long si vous étiez à nouveau
ministre de la Santé
pourquoi pas pas de problème avec cette
bon côté est-ce que vous pensez que vous
auriez le dernier mot
sur Bercy notamment sur le prix des
médicaments matures parce que je partage
votre avis ils sont importants on les a
on a passé notre temps à baisser leur
prix je pense qu'il faut qu'il soit
arrivé on voit bien qu'aujourd'hui ce
sont des médicaments à bas prix qui nous
manquent est-ce que vous pensez que vous
auriez vous arriveriez à convaincre le
ministre de l'Économie je vous remercie
emiliane Pomerol
oui merci madame la Présidente merci
Madame ministre et j'ai besoin de tendu
dans votre présentation que vous aviez
passé un petit peu de votre temps à vous
battre contre les contre les Big Pharma
et je voulais vous poser une question
précise par rapport aux agences je vais
le dire donc la thérapie génique de la
sclérose amitrophique
qui se qui a été oui vous parlez de la
thérapie génie contre la myotrophie
spinale qui a oui qui est à 2 millions
d'euros c'est ça 2 millions d'euros
c'est Necker qui en 95 avait trouvé le
défaut génétique c'est la recherche
au niveau de l'essai du CNRS et avec
l'argent du Téléthon qui a abouti aux
médicaments et puis la petite boîte
qu'il a fabriqué a été rachetée par
Novartis et Novartis arrive en dernier
et nos artistes dit 2 millions d'euros
à ce rythme là et vous l'avez souligné
comment cela va être soutenable pour la
sécurité sociale d'accepter des prix
pareil et qu'avez-vous fait pour lutter
contre un prix pareil vous avez un peu
la même question que Corinne que ma
collègue Corinne maire comment vous
parliez d'Europe et de nécessité
d'Europe comment face au karma
pourriez-vous ou avez-vous pu avoir une
discussion sur ce médicament particulier
mais c'est valable pour d'autres sur le
prix qui est demandé qui devient
effectivement exorbitant et qui est un
dévouement j'allais dire de l'argent
public en plus de l'importance de
l'argent qui a été mis par la recherche
publique dans ce cas précis
et donc moi je vais je vais compléter
insister sur une dimension qui est celle
de la gouvernance et alors j'oserais
dire le pilotage parce que c'est quand
même le terme qui nous a été proposé
dans pas mal d'auditions il y a un vrai
sujet depuis l'otage en tout cas sur la
pénurie de médicaments sont s'étaler sur
les politiques de santé en général avec
avec une question en fait de l'arbitrage
budgétaire vers 6 l'arbitrage sanitaire
on en est vraiment sur ces sujets là en
ce moment et puis surtout une
multiplicité d'acteurs avec une espèce
de commitologie un peu maladies
françaises même si chacun est important
peut-être
peut-être réfléchir à à une si ce n'est
une meilleure organisation en tout cas
avoir
une organisation qui permet qu'à un
moment le la gouvernance soit politique
et non et politique au sens sanitaire du
terme et non politique au sens stratégie
budgétaire systématique ou au sens
ayant d'autres objets que celle de bien
traiter les gens dans les meilleures
conditions possibles c'est à dire par
exemple
ne pas considérer que l'équilibre
financier de la sécurité sociale même si
on y tient énormément parce que c'est
aussi en soi une politique de santé pour
notre pays l'accès aux soins pour tous
que l'équilibre budgétaire de la
sécurité sociale soit l'alpha et l'oméga
de ce qu'on concède dans l'enveloppe
budgétaire du médicament
alors ah oui
[Musique]
ce président mignon je sais pas si je
dois vous appeler encore président mais
on vous êtes président à vie en fait
pour moi excusez-moi
oui là où je parle du Prix européen par
exemple c'est que le problème c'est que
souvent le prix est d'abord fixé aux
États-Unis il est alors pour vous
expliquer la probabilité la chaîne que
suit le prix du médicament dans le monde
en fait les Big Pharma commencent
toujours à demander l'autorisation de
mission de marché à la FDA américaine la
FDA accorde l'autorisation ce qui veut
dire que le produit peut être
commercialisé mais les Américains n'ont
pas l'équivalent de la HAS françaises ou
l'équivalent du Nice ils n'ont pas de ce
qu'on appelle le technology ils n'ont
pas d'agence d'évaluation et donc le
prix est négocié directement entre les
assureurs Américains et les Big Pharma
et souvent les assureurs ils se fichent
complètement que le prix soit élevé
puisque de toute façon il montera ils
monteront leur prime d'assurance c'est
le système américain très libéral donc
vous partez avec un prix américain très
haut
parce qu'il n'a pas été le médicament
n'a pas été évalué sur des critères
scientifiques sur sa valeur ajoutée il
n'y a pas d'ASMR aux États-Unis
l'équivalent de ce qu'on fait nous à la
chaise et donc il part d'une négociation
simple avec Kaiser Permanente ou je ne
sais trop quel système d'assurance et et
il prend en compte en plus la publicité
vous avez le droit aux États-Unis de
faire des publicités il y en a partout
pour les médicaments à la télé sur les
anti-hypertension etc tout ça fait
partie du coût des médicaments et on se
retrouve après avec un médicament ou les
Big Pharma demande la même européenne
un an plus tard en général ou six mois
plus tard puis l'évaluation nous par nos
agences de ce qu'on appelle helf
technologie assistante qui vont
positionner le médicament sur sa valeur
ajoutée pour aller négocier le prix mais
vous partez d'un prix de départ
américain très élevé et ce corridor
américain européen nous enferme un peu
alors c'est c'est la raison pour
laquelle je pense que si on doit revoir
le prix des médicaments c'est
aujourd'hui les Européens qui doivent se
mobiliser pour changer le système
vraiment changer cette cette
ce récit qui n'est plus supportable en
fait voilà le marché français n'est pas
un marché américain les patients
français ont tous accès aux médicaments
c'est un marché où il y a 100% de
pénétration dans le marché c'est
extraordinaire il y a très peu de pays
qui sont qui font ça et donc on doit
promouvoir notre système de sécurité
sociale et de ce fait pouvoir négocier
les prix indépendamment des prix
américains de départ après vous posez la
question d'utiliser moi les médicaments
oh que oui si seulement on utilisait
moins les médicaments en général je
pense que nous utilisons quatre fois
plus d'antibiotiques que les pays
nordiques je pense pas qu'on fasse
beaucoup plus d'infections urinaires ou
d'angine donc en réalité on a une
facilité de prescription des
antibiotiques qui est absolument
effarantes on est le quatrième pays plus
prescripteur d'Europe je crois avec la
Grèce la Bulgarie et donc il y a une
manie et puis parce que les patients
aussi ont toujours l'impression qu'ils
vont être mieux soignés pour l'Orangine
virale si on leur donne des
antibiotiques donc il y a à la fois une
demande sociétale une facilité des
médecins voilà des habitudes qui se sont
prises alors est-ce que le port du
masque généralisé je crois que sur le
port du masque je vous laisserai
légiférer voilà
mais c'est sûr que si on se lavait un
peu plus les mains il y aurait moins de
gastro-entérite et si on portait le
masque quand on est malade vous savez
avant la crise bon ça n'a pas du tout
été dit mais
la DGS avait expérimenté en 2018 et 2019
deux grandes deux grands essais de port
du masque en population en général
pendant les épidémies de grippe on
voulait savoir si les gens allaient y
adhérer donc il y avait eu un essai en
Occitanie et un essai je ne sais où mené
par les ARS payés par la DGS ou pendant
les épidémies de grippe les médecins
traitants devaient prescrire des masques
aux malades et à leur famille ce qui
était les recommandations pour éviter la
transmission d'épidémie
les deux essais ont été des échecs
complets aboutissants à dire les
Français ne veulent pas de masque les
médecins et en fait on n'a pas réussi à
promouvoir ça alors que l'idée de la DGS
au départ était justement de réduire
l'impact des maladies infectieuses par
le port du masque en période épidémique
et ça n'a pas marché le covid a un peu
transformé les choses et voilà
comme quoi
nous sommes adaptables
madame vous me posiez la question de mon
incohérence entre transparence et rabais
en fait j'entends tout à fait votre
marque elle est évidente mais en fait
on peut pas être transparent tout seul
c'est ça que je voulais dire c'est qu'il
y a une question de timing pourquoi pas
la transparence si on est tous on est
tous sur la table en même temps mais si
la France est transparente et que
l'Allemagne ne l'est pas et que je
connais pas les rabais des Allemands là
je vais être en grande difficulté pour
négocier donc
si transparence il doit y avoir à ce
moment-là c'est tout le monde ensemble
sinon on se tire une balle dans le pied
dans notre capacité de négociation donc
c'est une question de timing de
dynamique collective en fait d'où le
fait que je n'avais pas effectivement
poussé cette voilà
est-ce que le prix du médicament doit
être un modification de compétences
européenne moi alors je suis une
Européenne convaincue je pense que sur
un tas tout un tas de sujets aujourd'hui
les chemins européens est le seul valide
et probablement sur la santé sur un
certain nombre de choses également sur
l'évaluation des médicaments c'est
peut-être faire la négociation du prix
même si nos marchés sont très différents
on peut pas comparer le marché français
avec le marché et polonais ou
je pense alors je pense qu'on est on
commence à être un petit pays à
l'échelon international face à ce que je
disais tout à l'heure face à des marchés
émergents où les gens se soignent
Indonésie 300 millions d'habitants
Brésil 300 millions d'habitants faut
qu'on puisse négocier voilà et donc je
pense qu'il y a une réflexion avant au
niveau européen sur les compétences
européennes sur la santé qui sont
aujourd'hui extrêmement faibles
voilà
et d'ailleurs je vais je vais peut-être
quelqu'un m'a posé la question
[Musique]
de ah oui ah oui je crois que c'est vous
madame impair vous m'avez posé la
question de savoir si j'avais jamais été
tenté de demander à mes collègues
européens le prix et en fait non alors
le pire c'est que nous nous avons la HS
qui centralise l'évaluation la
négociation a faite avec le CEPS et donc
c'est assez centralisé mais dans la
plupart des pays
l'équivalent de la chaise c'est à dire
le Half technology assassin qui évalue
l'intérêt d'un médicament par rapport à
l'existant et donc va permettre la
fixation du prix elle se fait au niveau
des régions en Italie ces régionales en
Espagne ces régionales en Allemagne en
Allemagne non je crois pas en Suisse
donc
en réalité je suis même pas sûr que mes
collègues européens sachent le prix des
médicaments et c'est pas le même prix
d'une région à l'autre vous pouvez être
en Espagne avoir accès à certains
médicaments selon la région vous habitez
et pas dans d'autres régions
donc il y a quand même une remise à plat
général comment une région peut évaluer
la qualité d'un médicament quand je vois
le travail que fait la chaise
d'instruction de dossiers en général
c'est des petits bureaux avec deux trois
personnes qui essayent de positionner la
valeur ajoutée du médicament dans la
stratégie thérapeutique mais non pas les
moyens donc je trouve plus là on a une
faiblesse par rapport à l'industrie
pharma et encore la France n'est pas la
plus faible voilà
alors même un père vous m'avez posé la
question
traçabilité alors la sérialisation elle
s'est mise en place quand j'étais
ministre donc je pense que ça va changer
la donne vraiment et je pense qu'on est
très protégé effectivement grâce à la
séréalisation
après je suis pas capable de voir
l'impact aujourd'hui sur la traçabilité
toute la chaîne je ne suis plus en
fonction depuis maintenant trois ans
c'est difficile pour moi de me faire une
idée sur des sujets aussi technique en
fait j'ai plus du tout accès
alors si j'étais de nouveau ministre
est-ce que je serais capable d'avoir le
dernier mot sur Bercy
j'ai deux remarques j'ai deux remarques
d'abord pour être honnête j'ai plus peur
de grand chose donc je pense que si
j'étais de nouveau ministre je pense que
ma capacité d'action serait un peu
décuplée par rapport à ce que j'étais il
y a trois ans objectivement
ce qui ne suis pas en force donc là je
suis assez costaud deuxièmement
bercy n'a pas le dernier mot sur des
médicaments ça serait fou de laisser
croire aux Français que il y a le
moindre arbitrage financier sur l'accès
aux soins c'est pas vrai
on baisse les prix on
va mais je n'ai jamais vu un patient
français et quand j'étais ministre je
m'en supportais garante et je vous
donnerai deux trois exemples je n'ai
jamais vu impatient français ne pas
accéder à un médicament efficace parce
qu'après vous avez tout tout
ces filières sectaires où on vous vend
un médicament miracle en Allemagne ou en
Suisse etc mais tout ça ne sont pas je
parle d'un médicament efficace évalué
par la chasse de renommer internationale
je n'ai jamais vu un patient français ne
pas y accéder pour des raisons de prix
jamais
vous aviez la tu qui permettait de
gagner du temps sur la fixation du prix
maintenant vous avez l'accès précoce
je reviendrai sur l'accès précoce parce
que je n'y étais pas favorable mais je
vous expliquerai pourquoi
mais en réalité
merci n'a jamais empêché
qu'un médicament soit accessible sur le
marché la preuve et j'en reviens à votre
question madame le prix du médicament de
thérapie génique sur la myotrophie
spinale qui coûte 2 millions d'euros les
malades qui en ont besoin l'auront
évidemment et moi j'ai le souvenir
d'avoir eu des traitements qui étaient
disponibles aux États-Unis des
traitements innovants qui n'étaient pas
encore accessibles en Europe pour des
enfants atteints de cancer
j'ai demandé à ce que le ministère
envoie ses enfants sur les frais de la
sécurité sociale aux États-Unis pour se
faire traiter nous avons payé l'échec de
l'hospitalisation de ces enfants voilà
il y a vraiment aujourd'hui un accès aux
soins dans notre pays qui était
exceptionnel et je veux le redire c'est
ce qui fait la force de notre pays et
bercy n'a jamais eu le dernier mot pour
empêcher l'accès les Anglais ne sont pas
comme ça les Anglais quand les
médicaments sont trop chers et et
dépasse une certaine somme pour une
année de vie gagnée
il ne commercialise pas le médicament et
le rembourse pas quand ils ont vu que
les prix des médicaments anticancéreux
étaient tellement importants ils ont
fait une enveloppe spéciale pour les
médicaments anti-cancéreux qui allaient
au-delà de du prix qu'ils avaient fixé
pour une année de vie gagnée et même
dans cette enveloppe il n'acceptait pas
les médicaments les plus chers et dans
les pathologies dont j'avais la charge
je voyais des patients anglais venir
acheter au prix fort les médicaments en
France parce qu'il n'y accédait pas en
Angleterre et des médicaments que je
prescrivais tous les jours en
consultation sans même me poser la
question donc voilà il faut rappeler
quand même en français que nous avons un
système de soins hors norme
donc il n'y a pas d'arbitrage entre
sanitaire et et
je réponds en fait à Madame un président
il n'y a pas d'arbitrage entre sanitaire
et budgétaire
le sanitaire l'emporte toujours et
heureusement toujours vous voyez
qu'avoir le covid
voyez bien que le sanitaire l'emporte et
forcément
oui mais là c'est ponctuellement et en
situation de crise très clairement quand
même l'enveloppe médicament n'est pas
non plus dans une progression à la
hauteur des besoins dans le PLFSS donc
ça c'est quand même un arbitrage
budgétaire jusqu'à preuve du contraire
et la baisse quand même drastique
itérative de certains médicaments dont
l'intérêt thérapeutique est inégalé
inégalé c'est-à-dire de pas avérer c'est
inégalé en termes de qualité et quand
même un sujet oui mais ça revient au
point que je donc je vous parlais tout à
l'heure je pense que en fait on a une
politique du prix du médicament qui est
beaucoup trop macro donc on leur fixe un
plafond de pourcentage d'augmentation
qui est en gros les pourcentages de
longs dames 2,3% etc et en fait vous
mettez là dedans des carottes et des
choux en fait des médicaments
indispensables fait d'intérêt
thérapeutique majeurs et des trucs
franchement voilà qui sont remboursés
aujourd'hui à 15% ou 30% et qui n'ont
pas beaucoup d'intérêt donc en réalité
on devrait pouvoir être beaucoup plus
discriminant et moi je trouve que si on
veut maintenir ces médicaments anciens
et renégocier des prix pour que ces
médicaments anciens continuent d'être
efficace il faut qu'on arrête cette
échelle de perroquet sur l'innovation
jusqu'à quand on va augmenter les prix
le jour ou trois mois de vie gagner nous
coûteront un million d'euros
à un moment faut bien il faut bien
s'arrêter l'innovation elle n'a pas de
prix jusqu'au moment où on peut plus la
payer quoi donc c'est là où on doit
quand même
revenir à une négociation qui est
indépendante de la SMR et qui retire
vers le bas
qui revient à évaluer quand même
l'intérêt intrinsèque et pas simplement
l'intérêt par rapport à l'existant parce
que l'intérêt par rapport à l'existant
il amène toujours un prix supérieur et
l'intérêt intrinsèque il doit quand même
voilà revenir à la réalité comparer je
vous dis il faut qu'on se faudrait
comparer ce qu'on
au coût d'une vie d'une année de vie
gagner dans telle pathologie par rapport
à tel autre et là on se rendrait compte
quand même de l'un des sens de certains
prix de médicaments voilà donc c'est
pour ça je suis pas je pense que si
votre commission à la fin il faut
augmenter globalement l'enveloppe à
louer aux médicaments en France pour
éviter les pénuries je pense que on est
mort parce que on va on va rentrer dans
un cercle vicieux les industriels feront
plus encore plus de pénurie pour qu'on
paye encore plus cher c'est un discours
qui n'est pas audible pour moi sur on va
essayer de mettre un peu l'intelligence
excusez-moi c'était c'était voilà et
enfin j'en viens aux médicaments de la
FM Téléthon alors vous parlez d'un
médicament qui a un modèle très
particulier je vais être très prudente
dans la façon dont je m'exprime c'est un
modèle qui a été mis en place par la fn
Téléthon qui est très particulier en
fait
on est sur des pathologies orpheline sur
lequel effectivement les Big Pharma
travaillent relativement peu la plupart
des innovations sont
issues de la recherche fondamentale sur
lequel l'État met beaucoup d'argent les
brevets issus de l'Inserm du CNRS sont
licenciés à AFM Téléthon qui
en fait aide à la constitution de
biotech
elle a dans son spectre en fait vraiment
une stratégie quasiment
d'industrialisation des médicaments pour
les maladies orphelines génétique et
c'est très bien mais à la fin c'est
biotech sont rachetés au prix fort par
des Big Pharma et ses médicaments nous
sont
fournis à des prix fixés par les Big
Pharma qui ne tient pas du tout con de
la chaîne de ce qu'on a mis dedans
notamment à la France moi j'ai envie de
dire à la FM Téléthon quand vous vendez
les biotech à l'industrie pharma ma
négocier au moins que le prix pour la
France qui a mis l'argent au départ soit
bon il se trouve que j'étais plus en
place au moment de la négociation de ça
mais je pense que dans le modèle il y a
il y a cet aspect là de reprendre en
compte ce que l'État français et la
recherche publique a mis dans le
développement initial dans les salaires
des chercheurs dans les structures de
recherche etc
voilà
la gouvernance et le pilac gouvernance
pilotage pour employer le terme le plus
adéquat j'ai peur de pas
je
ne sais pas vous aider sur le pilotage
je pense qu'il faut je pense qu'il faut
un pilotage dédié parce qu'en fait c'est
très technique extrêmement technique il
y a très peu de gens qui maîtrisent en
fait la totalité de la chaîne et qui
connaissent vraiment et qui soit aussi
scientifique pour être capable de
négocier avec les industriels sur leur
stratégie cachée elles sont bien
montrées dans dans le livre notamment
sur les niches thérapeutiques etc en
fait c'est un métier en soi et donc je
pense que si on devait faire quelque
chose ce serait une délégation
interministérielle quelque chose de ce
type là qui voit les aspects industriels
les espérer réglementaires les espèces
scientifiques
avec le Ministère de la Recherche
d'investissement je pense que Mister la
santé est un peu faible tout seul
là-dessus franchement
voilà
et puis pour terminer pourquoi j'étais
pas très favorable avec ses précoces qui
a été mis en place par rapport aux etu
c'est qu'en fait l'accès précoce et des
Anglais nous avait alerté sur ce point
alors il est très très bien pour les
malades en fait puisque tous les
médicaments soient accessibles tout de
suite avant l'évaluation par la chaise
mais les Allemands nous avaient ça en
place et nous avait alerté sur leur
accès précoce à eux quand j'étais à la
SS en disant que comme c'était les
industriels qui fixaient le prix de
départ en fait une fois que le
médicament était évalué il y avait
quasiment plus d'espace de négociation
parce qu'ensuite les industrialises ah
oui non mais si vous nous faites un prix
trop bas sur notre médicament on arrête
de le commercialiser et comme les
malades étaient déjà traités depuis un
an que les médecins avaient l'habitude
de le prescrire etc en fait on était
plus ils étaient plus ils n'étaient plus
en mesure de négocier en Allemagne et il
m'avait dit surtout ne faites pas ça et
quand j'ai vu l'accès précoce mis en
place en France ou justement c'est de
l'industriel qui fixe le prix je me suis
bah ça y est on va se retrouver dans la
même difficulté de négociation voilà
donc je suis favorable évidemment un
accès précoce des médicaments en France
mais je trouve que voilà le flying le
cadre global n'est pas assez réglementé
voilà je m'arrêterai là merci beaucoup
merci madame la ministre